>> Ryan: HEAT ARE OVER THE
LIMIT.
>> Hubie: THIS IS BIG.
THE KEY NOW YOU HAVE TO TAKE A
HIGH PERCENTAGE SHOT.
>> Ryan: AND MIAMI WILL WANT TO
GO QUICK ENOUGH TO PLAY STRAIGHT
UP DEFENSE.
>> Hubie: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Ryan: TWO FOR ONE
OPPORTUNITY, BUTLER PATIENTLY
MASSAGING HIS WAY DOWN, ROBINSON
GIVES IT UP.
BACK TO BUTLER, A THREE, NO.
BACK PASS, ARIZA GIVES IT UP TO
DRAGIC.
HE GOES, A THREE TO TIE IT AT
107.
AND NOW MILWAUKEE WITH THE SHOT
CLOCK TURNED OFF CAN HOLD FOR A
POTENTIAL GAME WINNER.
CROWD RISING TO ITS FEET.
MIDDLETON, FIVE SECONDS LEFT IN
OVERTIME.
MIDDLETON WITH TWO, MIDDLETON,
YOU BET.
HE GOT IT.
WITH 0.5 TO GO.
KHRIS MIDDLETON PUTS THE BUCKS
UP TWO HERE IN GAME ONE.
>> Hubie: THAT WAS A BIG-TIME
PROFESSIONAL MOVE BY A PLAYER
WHO HAS BEEN PLAYING ALL DAY
WITH GREAT CONFIDENCE, 27 POINT,
JUST WATCH AS HE CREATES THE
SPACE RIGHT THERE.
HE GOT TO HIS SPOT AND ONCE HE
ELEVATED, THE DEFENSE THERE GOES
RIGHT BY HIM.
SEE, ROBINSON TRIES TO PICK UP
HERE, RIGHT THERE.
THERE'S THE FADE.
NOT ONLY DOES HE ELEVATE, BUT HE
GETS THE FADE AND HE HITS THE
BOTTOM OF THE NET.
10 FOR 22 FROM THE FLOOR TODAY.
JUST A GREAT OFFENSIVE DISPLAY
BY MIDDLETON.
>> Ryan: KHRIS MIDDLETON HAS THE
CROWD GOING NUTS OUTSIDE FISERV
FORUM.
HE TOLD US LATE GAME EXECUTION
WOULD BE THE KEY AGAINST MIAMI.
HE FELT BETTER ABOUT HIS TEAM'S
ABILITY TO EXECUTE IN CLOSE
GAMES THIS YEAR AS OPPOSED TO
LAST POSTSEASON.
MIAMI WITH THE BASKETBALL, THEY
CAN ADVANCE IT AFTER THE
TIME-OUT.
DOWN TWO, STILL PLENTY OF TIME
TO CATCH AND SHOOT.
>> Hubie: CATCH AND SHOOT.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
I SAID HE HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS NOW.
WHERE THE SCREENS WILL COME
FROM.
THEY DON'T HAVE A CHANCE NOW TO
THROW THE BALL INBOUNDS, CATCH
IT AND MAKE ANOTHER PLAY.
SO IT HAS TO COME RIGHT OFF OF
THE PASS FROM THE OUT OF BOUNDS.
A KEY GUY NOW IS THE PASSER.
>> Ryan: DRAGIC WILL INBOUND.
MIAMI DOWN TWO, 0.5 TO GO AFTER
MIDDLETON'S JUMPER PUT THE BUCKS
UP BY TWO POINTS.
>> Hubie: NOW --
>> Ryan: WITH GIANNIS IN FRONT.
MIAMI, NO TIME-OUTS REMAINING,
BUTLER, DID HE GET IT OFF?
THAT'S IT.
GAME ONE BELONGS TO THE
MILWAUKEE BUCKS.
PERSEVERANCE IN OVERTIME.
AND ONE FINAL DEFENSIVE STAND
HANDS MILWAUKEE AN OPENING WIN
IN THIS BEST OF SEVEN SERIES.
>> Hubie: THAT WAS A GREAT
DEFENSIVE PLAY ON BUTLER WHO
CAME UP, UP THE LANE AND MADE
HIS MOVE ACROSS IN ORDER TO
CATCH THAT PASS.
BUT THE DEFENDER RIGHT ON TOP.
HE GETS A PIECE ON THE RISE.